emmanuel macron comptait beaucoup
s'appuyer sur angela merkel ça fait déjà
entre les difficultés qu'elle a formé un
gouvernement
le vote d'hier l'alliance le binôme ans
à être très bien fonctionné en plus les
allemands aujourd'hui on me dit que
madame merkel a engueulé sont mises de
l'agriculture en lui disant tu avais
demandé alors je sais pas s'il ya le
téléphone c'est la dépêche james à elle
n'est pas arrivée à temps dans une autre
formulation non parce qu'il faut pas non
plus oublier que les allemands ont une
très grande société qui s'appelle
bailleurs qui raconte à acheter sans
racheter monsanto
donc il ya des intérêts économiques dont
on nous parle pas aujourd'hui on nous
amuse avec il faut à 53 ans
mais il ya des intérêts économiques et
mais c'est surtout que l'europe que
voulait diriger madame merkel et que
surtout macron voulait diriger avec
madame merkel en ce moment ça va de l